[Music]
because we have uh again a very
prestigious world-renowned drug smuggler
in the room who happens to be japanese
so it's down to two today's world news
a cocaine shipment uh-huh worth 83
million dollars gets delivered to
supermarkets by mistake oh [ __ ] was it
inviting was it a plane
was it a plane was it a plane delivery
the process has to be the plane
is sold for the drugs and then you
deliver the drugs i think that's
definitely a good fear you don't crash a
plane into the supermarket that doesn't
work that way but you need a supplier
wherever you land right yeah
that's true stop making it real dude
you're making it real dude
sorry you're right i'm sorry guys this
is like the one hey can we edit that out
favorite confident
too [ __ ] real too
all right so drug smugglers lost out on
a shipment of cocaine hidden in crates
of bananas did they disguise it as
bananas or because i saw that i saw that
video of them like they disguised it as
like potatoes or whatever and then oh
yeah that one i think i think that one
was actually better because they also
did that with onions but this one is
just like there's creative bananas and
then under like the very surface level
of like six bananas there's blocks of
cocaine they're just [ __ ] drinks
there's just one bunch like on top
you guys watch one banana value
entertainment
so he has a podcast that has all these
like former mob bosses and all these
people right and then there was this
really [ __ ] interesting dude
and um
he was a smuggler he was a dealer and he
was like a top guy and he was he was
basically saying how like the medellin
cartel all those guys are actually not
that big but the cia fbi they just want
to create a big file on these dudes and
he goes the big dudes are actually
owners of farms and banana companies and
all this so this makes it kind of go
chiquita banana people are really like
pablo
yeah the lady with the banana and the
fruit on her head she's the real escobar
the front dude do you think she's the
one disguising this though because this
is pretty this is pretty [ __ ] disgusting
the chinese word on there the chinese
word what is that
no no it's not king it looks like an h
yeah which way so is this a asian
company no right no chiquita banana
she's like the ultimate drug lord dude
the chiquita banana lady so this
actually uh the crates of bananas uh
were supposed to be delivered or were
delivered to czech supermarkets oh
before it could be intercepted in
germany the entire europe yeah the
entire hall was eventually seized by
cops when supermarket workers at
different stores across the country
started discovering the powder filled
packages in the banana crates yeah oh it
was in it hit different markets yeah it
got distributed like an actual product
yeah what's funny do you really believe
that it was accidentally sent to marcus
or when the wrong person at the market
discovered it did the contacts from
those markets who were insiders say hey
those weren't meant to be sent here oh i
feel like that's what happened i feel
like that was the network that these
people are supposed to receive it and
then it's the wrong person just or all
these supermarkets are pissed that they
don't have enough bananas they just have
all these [ __ ] coconuts that's an
even bigger crisis that's like a really
really uh
big shipment to be like you know fumbled
by one random ins and then they would
and then they would give up all of them
yeah that's like that's like a lot of
money i feel like you would be more
scared that like you'd die because you'd
have to like give it up and rat on them
for saving the like but the drug dealer
why would they make like why would they
make a mistake this big because it was a
canned version of the drug world
working
at the budget
can our very own can win
okay
so you don't have faith in can to be an
international drug dealer can was their
tech guy
and he was doing logistics but what
ended up happening was he took a big
[ __ ] hit started playing guitar and
then the order came up and he's all like
he's just he's playing guitar instead of
doing his job which is my [ __ ] 83
million dollars of coke
and then he switched up the order
and then he's like oh [ __ ] bro
give him this video sorry guys
and they were like you know what it's
all good he's like hurry up you guys got
to start because lunch is coming
can you guys just do that whole shipment
again
can we retake it from the top footage
obtained from the czech police shows a
police officer and a sniffer dog
inspecting a shipment of several crates
of bananas which the doggle oh yeah
just the one right here
that's right
it's scooby-doo yeah i don't know
because that's like what other dog
horses is there this is true make a new
dog voice right now go three two one
well there's the rock and the new super
dogs one what
the rocks the rock is always the rock
though it sounds like the rock
anyways um
which have reportedly originated in
colombia so uh unsurprising oh the dog
voice yeah dude
columbia finished finish the article as
a dog still scooby doo finish the
article as a dog though
the british one a british one how the
[ __ ] do you do this try just a british
bulldog with eczema yeah yeah
i wanna hear the skin flakes listen
rock some press cocaine see that was
pretty good good that was good
51 pounds
see it's like really good i'm so glad i
didn't do it so it's like scottish kind
of first person narrative of the dog
sniffing for the drugs oh
don't think uh
first that cracker
it could wind up both here boy here boy
roll like that what is that
what's rum roll because he's seen he's
seen the cocaine he's like oh no oh
this is the first this one is the first
video we do immediately after our guest
leaves yeah yeah
thank god our guest was not right grow
ring
do you think the detective is like oh
geez
do you think that there's any cocaine in
these scoob
jeepers that's your legal contraband
[Laughter]
like like that's 84 million dollars
those aren't scooby snacks there
you should alert the authorities
hey do you think kids nowadays still
[ __ ] know scooby-doo yeah dude
they rebooted over and over yeah man but
do they talk like that though dude look
how viral the velma and [ __ ] those
like little porn things i was like where
are you going with this i was like oh
you went exactly where i thought that's
true there's so many cam girls dressing
like belle if the porn in cosplay is
popular then velma's the orange sweater
oh why do you know that
what that and glasses are the only two
defining features of velma and then the
other one is uh what's your name daphne
daphne's yeah yeah
so now that we established the
scooby-doo characters what else happens
in this article drugs delivered as
blocks of press cocaine with a total
weight of
1851 pounds and with a street value of
approximately 83 million dollars
had transited via the german port of
hamburg the largest port in europe after
rotterdam in the netherlands before
arriving in the czech republic where
they all were able to watch velma [ __ ]
on pornhub
wow
what a plug the czech republic is where
they have those uh [ __ ] rooms where the
girls are saying [ __ ] rooms i thought he
was really gonna say something like
international when the bridge works
they have the [ __ ] rooms where the girls
are in different positions they're like
glory holes and you just walk in and you
do different positions like you walk
into a room and it's like there's a
doggies that that doggy style you have
to go through spread leg
no i mean there's just the body like
they're just laying there it's a little
gross yeah it's pretty gross what are
they doing before you walk in like
sit-ups or something
they're chilling yeah what do they do no
no like you see like uh
backspin yeah just like it's just like a
room and then they're in different
positions is that real it's just glory
holes though yeah it's glory it's not a
glory there's no floor it's like yeah
it's not a hole it's like it's there's
only one hole holes no there's many
holes right sometimes there's two
basically a half body maybe it's a glory
torso i don't know
glory oh it's like the lower torso yeah
yeah yeah so adjust their legs just trap
these these people there's nothing on
the other side by the way it's like
literally just a corpse no
but on the portal you can see their
other side they're dead i know
i was hoping someone would pick up on
the joke like jeez that's necrophilia
man
[Laughter]
so you do the plays man it's the thing
that dogs say they go row damn that's
crazy
83 they always do the street price
because it makes you go wow because i
know it might be like 10 million that's
like the high like the wholesale i don't
know it's kind of like
their price
we can't tell them our price but street
value is really nice what do you do if
you work at the supermarket and then you
stumble upon this package and you're the
guy that finds the one stack of bananas
are you are you in a managed position
and are you in an area that where there
are security cameras why does that
matter to you yes yes i just want to
know the variables for ryan answered
because
immediately he's thinking about all the
exits i know him look at his face right
but regardless even if i so even if i
steal it i probably have to report it
because
even if you steal it now you've stolen
like some drug lords [ __ ] stash right
so they're gonna come after you that way
so you might as well fess up to the [ __ ]
rather be the dog that finds it and just
goes
it's like
you see you stumble upon cocaine damn i
wish i was a dog
what are they gonna do
i got eggs
one new yorker drug dog in the czech
republic he's like famous though he's
like really famous and he has a known
cocaine issue there's no limit to the
amount of dog voices we can make today
[Music]
you